este vídeo es innovador por varios
motivos uno de ellos es que vamos a
definir lo que es la varianza muestral
la segunda razón y muy importante es que
este vídeo está grabado en hd en alta
definición y la idea de grabarlo en hd
es que ustedes lo puedan ver más grande
y más claro que nunca antes pero bueno
antes de hablar de la varianza muestral
que por si es un tema bastante
interesante quitando del lado de hd voy
a hablar de la varianza que habíamos
definido para una población y la
varianza que habíamos definido para una
población la denota vamos con sigma
cuadrada con la letra griega sigma
elevado al cuadrado que te por si ella
es algo raro porque si ustedes se dan
cuenta tenemos una variable elevada al
cuadrado llamada varianza y ustedes van
a decir por qué no despejar la sigma
cuadrada y pasas el otro lado como raíz
pero el asunto está en que no tenemos
una variable elevada al cuadrado sino
más bien sigma cuadrada es como se
define varianza y bueno lo habíamos
definido como la diferencia que hay de
cualquiera de nuestros datos a la media
de nuestra
acción esto elevado al cuadrado y
después nos íbamos a tomar la suma de
todas estas diferencias porque para cada
dato hay una de estas diferencias es
decir la suma desde igual a uno hasta n
de la diferencia de xy menos mil elevado
al cuadrado y todo esto dividido entre
la cantidad de datos es decir entre en
recuerden que otra forma de ver a la
varianza era cómo tomar la media de las
distancias de cada uno de los datos a la
media elevado al cuadrado y es así cómo
definimos a la varianza poblacional
ahora hay que tener cuidado porque si
nosotros quisiéramos saber la varianza
de la altura de todos los hombres del
mundo pues tendríamos que ir a medir los
250 millones de hombres calcular la
media y después la distancia y todo el
procedimiento siguiente y no sé ustedes
pero a mí me suena un poco tardado y
algo complicado ir a medir a todos los
250 millones de hombres que hay entonces
para eso voy a definir en este vídeo la
varianza muestral y de manera análoga a
la media muestral si yo quería tomar
de una población de hombres no voy a
medir a todos tal vez pueda tomar
primero la media de una cierta muestra y
de ahí concluir algo entonces supongamos
que este grupo es toda la población
millones de datos o tal vez si es una
variable aleatoria datos que todavía no
podemos conocer y supongamos que me tomo
un conjunto más pequeño el cual es una
muestra de la población en un subgrupo
de mi grupo de la población ahora bien
la idea es estimar datos de esta muestra
para ello poder concluir algo sobre mi
población en eso se basa la estadística
inferencial si yo tengo un conjunto de
100 personas los cuales es decir un
cierto medicamento entonces tal vez lo
puedan decir que a toda la población les
sirva este medicamento ahora bien no
olviden que estamos hablando de una
muestra de la población no es lo mismo y
si nosotros sabemos la diferencia entre
la muestra y la población
podemos entender mucho más de la
estadística inferencial a lo que voy es
el tener conocimiento de la estadística
de la muestra nos puede ayudar a
describir mejor la población ya tener
una estimación de ciertos parámetros de
la población
vamos a recordar un poco lo que era la
media poblacional es decir de toda la
población la media poblacional la
definimos como la suma de todos los
datos dividido entre la cantidad de
datos es decir las sumas de igual a 1
hasta n de todos los datos de todos los
x subíndice y dividido entre n voy a
utilizar el color morado cada vez que
hable de la población y bueno desde
cuenta de lo importante que es la media
porque la media nos sirve para calcular
la varianza la varianza nos pide tener
la media ahora bien qué va a pasar si yo
tengo una muestra de la población
recuerden que una muestra de la
población no son todos los individuos de
la población solamente un conjunto
pequeño de individuos hace algunos
vídeos yo también había definido la
media muestral y en esta ocasión la voy
a utilizar la media muestral la de nota
va con una x con gorrito es decir con
una x con una barra encima y era muy
sencilla teníamos que ser también una
suma la suma de todos los datos de mi
muestra es decir la suma desde iu igual
a 1 hasta una n minúscula porque no son
todos los datos de la población sólo la
cantidad de datos que tengo en mi
muestra ya esto nos dividía entre
es decir es casi la misma fórmula la
diferencia es que en la media
poblacional me fijo en todos los datos
de mi población mientras que la media
muestra magnífico solamente en los datos
que me tome en mi muestra ahora bien
seguramente se están preguntando por qué
no si ya tengo la media muestral la
sustituyó en la varianza y así obtengo
la varianza muestral y ya se acabó el
problema sin embargo no es tan fácil
como parece
en esta ocasión voy a llamar a la
varianza muestral como ese elevado al
cuadrado recuerden que cuando es
variante poblacional tomo a sigma la
letra griega sigma que es equivalente a
la s solamente que en griego
sigma cuadrada y en este caso me voy a
tomar solamente ese cuadrado es decir
estoy denotando a la varianza muestral
como ese cuadrado y bueno ese cuadrada
que propiedades debe de tener a que va a
ser igual y bueno suena muy lógico
pensar que es lo mismo que la varianza
poblacional es decir tomamos a todos los
x is es decir a todos los datos de mi
muestra ojos de mi muestra y con cada
uno de ellos calculó la diferencia que
hay a mi media muestral es
x barra elevó esta diferencia al
cuadrado para que siempre sea positiva y
después me tomo la suma de todas ellas
es decir la suma desde igual a 1 y
paramos hasta n minúscula desde igual a
uno hasta n minúscula es muy importante
no tenemos toda la población solamente
los datos que tengo la muestra ya esto
lo divido entre n minúscula de hecho en
muchos libros denotan a la varianza
muestral como s cuadrada subíndice n n
porque no estamos refiriendo a que
tenemos n datos en nuestra muestra muy
bien y bueno a decir verdad esta fórmula
de la varianza muestral es una buena
estimación de la varianza sin embargo
cuál es el problema que hay detrás
fíjense muy bien esta idea me confundía
mucho y realmente no lo entendía muy
bien hasta que me puse a analizarla un
buen rato entonces voy a intentar
explicarlas y pongan mucha atención
supongamos que yo tengo un conjunto de
números aleatorios para esto voy a
dibujar una línea una línea que va a ser
una línea de números y en esta línea de
números no voy a tomar
varios números aleatorios supongamos que
me tomo este de aquí este dakar este
también este también este también los
puntos que estén a la derecha son más
grandes y los puntos que están a la
izquierda son más pequeños me tomo todos
estos de aquí es decir mi población es
aleatoria y bueno de esta población yo
me voy a tomar una muestra nota la
muestra también debe ser aleatoria no
puedo tomar una muestra que a mí me
convenga
entonces me tomo este este este también
una muestra que sea aleatoria ahora bien
supongamos que calculamos la media
muestral y es este punto de aquí y
después calculamos la varianza que hay
es decir la distancia que hay entre cada
uno de nuestros puntos de la muestra y
la media muestral y nos sale algo así
esta distancia esta distancia esta
distancia lo ponemos en la fórmula y
entonces obtenemos ya el numerito de la
varianza muestral si se dan cuenta en
este caso parece ser que la varianza
muestral es muy parecida a la varianza
poblacional supongamos que la media de
mi población de todo el promedio de toda
la población es esta de aquí se dan
cuenta es muy parecida a la varianza por
la
a la varianza muestral y entonces
dijimos ya le hicimos tenemos una muy
buena aproximación utilizando la
varianza muestral suficiente por ahorita
ahora bien qué pasa si tenemos la mala
suerte de tener una muestra muy distinta
a la que nos tomamos ahorita supongamos
que nuestra muestra está este dato este
dato este dato y este dato y después
vamos a calcular lo que es la media
muestral y se dan cuenta la media
muestral siempre queda en medio de los
datos estaría como por aquí por aquí
está la media muestral y después
calculamos la distancia que hay de cada
punto a la media muestral es este y este
y este entonces al meterlo en la
varianza que creen vamos a obtener un
valor muy alejado al valor real de la
varianza poblacional la varianza en esta
muestra va a ser muy distinto a la
varianza poblacional porque por ejemplo
en este caso la varianza es muy pequeña
y si nos fijamos en la media de nuestra
población supongamos que está aquí y
tomamos la distancia de este punto o de
estas muestras a nuestra media
poblacional obtendríamos esta distancia
después obtendríamos esta distancia ésta
y esta otra distancia y si se dan cuenta
si sumamos estas distancias es mucho
mayor a las distancias que yo tenía de
color anaranjado y por lo tanto la
varianza va a ser mucho mayor a la
varianza muestral de este caso a ver a
verdaderamente otra vez si tenemos una
muestra cuya media sea muy cercana a la
muestra de mi población entonces la
varianza muestral va a ser muy parecida
a la varianza poblacional y ahí no había
ningún problema sin embargo existe una
cierta probabilidad de tomarme una
muestra cuya media esté muy alejada de
la media poblacional y por lo tanto mi
varianza va a ser mucho menor a la
varianza poblacional y en este caso no
me serviría esa fórmula es más si
ustedes me están entendiendo al menos el
10% de lo que le estoy diciendo les
puedo asegurar que ya son estudiantes
bastante buenos en estadística
inferencial ya están del otro lado son
estudiantes de estadística muy avanzados
porque todo de lo que hemos platicado
hasta ahorita es para crearles la
intuición de que la varianza tomada de
esta manera es
menor a la varianza poblacional por lo
tanto cuál va a ser la varianza que esté
no tan sesgada o una mejor aproximación
a la varianza poblacional y bueno para
eso se usa la famosísima s cuadrada no
voy a tener mucho tiempo de probarles de
una manera mucho más formal que esta es
una mejor aproximación sin embargo si
quiero utilizar una fórmula de una
varianza no tan sesgada utilicen ese
cuadrado que en muchos libros la denotan
como ese cuadrado subíndice n menos 1 y
su fórmula es la siguiente tomemos la
diferencia de todos mis puntos o todos
mis datos de mi muestra menos la media
muestral elevemos las al cuadrado y
hagamos la suma desde igual a uno hasta
n hasta aquí va todo normal pero la
diferencia es que hay que dividirlo
entre n menos 1 es decir entre la
cantidad de datos de la muestra menos 1
y si se dan cuenta si yo divido entre n
menos 1 por lo tanto el valor que yo
obtengo al calcular ese cuadrado
subíndice n menos 1 va a ser mayor que
el valor que obtenía al calcular ese
cuadro
el subíndice n de hecho hay otra forma
de escribir está cuadrada subíndice n 1
pero me estoy dando cuenta que estamos
muy apresurados en el tiempo por lo
tanto espero que hayan entendido un poco
toda esta abstracción que hemos hecho en
este vídeo la analicen y la repasan un
poco y no se pierdan los siguientes
vídeos que voy a seguir hablando de
varianza nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo